what up space fam golden here from anime
upper and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story
specifically today we are going to cover
some of the craziest spoilers we've ever
seen I am not overplaying this this
could easily turn out to be the most
hype chapter in the history of One Piece
if you do enjoy these spoiler reviews
before the full translated page shot
through reviews and want to keep them
coming you know what to do Channel
parking with it and smash that like
button always be a smashing pirate king
not a passing Orochi join the nakama
today by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss the
full review later in the week or other
one piece videos and updates now without
further Ado let's jump into It spoilers
and all we had a really long break after
the last chapter and it was a banger so
we couldn't complain it was revealed not
only that Luffy was a new yonko but also
that buggy buggy D clown himself was a
new yonko a revelation that took the one
piece Community by storm and I'm not
surprised and Oda did not disappoint
with this comeback chapter either he
definitely came back with a bang an even
bigger bang potentially and something
we've been waiting for since chapter 1
has finally happened something I've been
saying for a while should be happening
soon but first let's start with the
title of this chapter which may be your
favorite legendary dog in Pokemon Entei
to be fair my favorite was the ice
legendary dog I believe it was suicune
but I think we all remember Entei from
getting his own movie although I knew
for a long time that Entei was a
legendary dog in Pokemon even before I
knew what anime was I never thought to
look up the meaning but a quick Google
search will let us know that it can mean
emperor of fire or flames in Japanese
very interesting that makes sense for
ante the dog I suppose but it will make
all the more sense for one piece and
it'll be all the more hype as we're
about to see we got a one-piece color
spread coming this chapter and it could
not sound better it's gonna be a color
spread of the new yonko namely of buggy
Shanks Blackbeard and Luffy this sounds
like the kind of cover spread I want to
use a poster and just stick it on the
wall in my room the rest are the ones
containing Nami on the beach we're told
greenbull has a logia and not a mythical
Zone which honestly is probably a good
move since if I think about it we've
already had a lot of mythical zones
especially considering the fact that
it's supposed to be the rarest category
I get that Oda probably doesn't want to
Kill the Magic by having too many but at
the same time they're so hyped so I'd
personally forgive the quantity the
logia is called morimori no me and of
course I looked up Modi on Google and it
comes out as the Japanese word for
Forest so he has the forest forest fruit
and that is very cool because it's very
Broad and potentially Greenville can use
any ability you can find in a forest
we've already seen Roots but I'm sure he
has plenty more tricks up his sleeves
and again this reminds me even more of
hashirama from Naruto now and you know
how revered he was as the First Hokage
and how revered his wood style was as
well so I think Oda is really trying to
build up green bull even more here we
know Green bowl is a approaching the
party with our main characters in the
last chapter and we're told in this one
Yamato hits Greenville in the head on
the one hand this is hype because we're
going to get this highly anticipated
fight to start on the other hand though
Yamato has officially joined the crew
yet and it would suck like really hard
if green bull injures her so badly or
even kills her so she can't either way
I'm hoping backup isn't far behind since
this dude just took out queen and king
like they were nothing the most hyped
part of this overall hype chapter comes
next we are told Shanks you heard that
right the pirate from chapter one who
inspired Luffy's journey and who I made
a one hour long video about Link in the
description yes that red-haired yonko he
is on the shores of get this wano
country and he says it's time to go for
the one piece wow I got goosebumps just
reading that part to myself this is
insane on so many levels and let's cover
a couple of these levels one of course
it's the big moments set up in the
beginning that Luffy will meet Shanks
again when he's a great pirate that was
25 years ago and now that moment is
finally here I've also been saying now
for a while that it's time for them to
meet because Luffy has undeniably become
a great pirate especially after gear
pipe being the strongest creature in the
world and becoming a yonko two the
implication here is that Shanks and
Luffy are going for the one piece
together now this may very well be
Complicated by Blackbeard at some point
but having a Luffy Shanks Alliance
making their way for the one piece is
amazing to think about not to mention
the fact that the series is called one
piece and we have Shanks mentioning how
the time has come to get it so hype one
can't even verbalize how big of a deal
this is if you guys recall when he was a
kid shank stayed with a sick buggy when
Roger went for the final Island so he
never sighed for himself in fact shank
said that they meaning he and buggy
would go with their own ship one day now
that time appears to have come and if we
take the flashback into account and
specifically shanks's words yonko buggy
May well join them on their Journey
after all who didn't love seeing buggy
and Luffy work together at impel down it
was awesome it was peak one piece they
made such a hype team and by the way if
anyone wants to count how many times I
said hype in this video and post in the
comments feel free to but I think you'll
agree it's Justified because this
chapter was that word next as if that
wasn't enough greatness for a chapter we
get news about what happened with Sabo
you'll remember that we had that moment
where people were reading his name in
the papers and saying stuff like Sabo it
can't be true and Sabo said Ain't So and
Blackbeard said if the Navy is only
going to take it I might as well claim
the prize so at the time it seemed like
Oda was teasing that Sabo might be dead
but I never believed this personally
because in my view it would suck too
much for Sabo to be introduced after Ace
died for him to take his fruit no less
and then for him only to die as well and
thankfully that turned out to be a right
assumption the distressing news about
Sabo was not that he died it turns out
to be that he killed Cobra vivi's father
and the 12th king of alabasta now don't
get me wrong that is sad news that Cobra
is dead but at the same time you know if
we had to pick between Cobra and Sabo
you you know what I'm saying thus the
implication is that Blackbeard was
talking about alabasta and moved in to
take it for himself that would make
sense since as I said his Bounty had to
go up since last time because if it
didn't he'd be a yonko with a lower
Bounty than kid in law which doesn't
make any sense he probably succeeded in
taking alabasta among other things and
his bounty has likely bounced up
accordingly now what do I think about
whether Sabo actually killed Cobra one
of the rare good rulers well my opinion
is the same as dragons we gotta wait and
ascertain the truth right now my gut
feeling is that likely the the
government pinned it Ensemble and made
him a scapegoat but perhaps Sabo had a
good reason and did do it who knows all
I know is that Amon sabo's side and I'm
hyped to hear he's alive and kicking and
not only that we hear the Revolutionary
Army successfully helped Kuma this is
all the more hype since we know that
Sabo and the Revolutionary commanders
battled fujitora in Greenville in order
to rescue Kuma thus the implication is
that they overpowered them in battle or
at least held their own while rescuing
Kuma and retreating considering how much
Oda has hyped up green bull recently
that's insane to think about back in the
day I was disappointed when I found out
that the second in command of the
revolutionaries namely Sabo had a bounty
of only 602 million berries but Oda has
more than made up for it with this
chapter Sabo has actually been
proclaimed the emperor of the Flames AKA
a legendary dog in Pokemon implying he's
taken Luffy's spot as the new fifth
Emperor I mentioned that the spot might
go to someone as well well since we knew
that Luffy would be moving up to yonko
rather than fifth Emperor and I'm so
glad to see it go to Sabo it also makes
revolutionaries look so strong too which
I think they were missing in the past
it's awesome that their second in
command is an emperor and that's not
even to mention their boss Monkey D
Dragon the worst criminal in the world
and then at the end of the chapter akinu
talks to a new character you guys can
speculate as to who you think it is in
the comments but I'm content to let this
detail go for now and I'll Circle back
when we have more information with the
full translated chapter make sure you're
subscribed so you don't miss that and
thank God and Oda that we don't have a
break next week so we won't have to sit
on this bombshell of a chapter for long
without getting any answers smash that
like button if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more like it be a
smashing pirate king and not a passing
Orochi let me know how you enjoy these
chapter spoilers and what you think
you're going to rate this chapter when
it finally comes out in full this has to
be My View From just the spoilers alone
I'm gonna call it right now this has to
be a 10 out of 10. so many crazy moments
and reveals not to mention so many fan
favorite characters coming in in Epic
fashion do not miss my full detailed
chat review and other one piece videos
and updates join the nakama right now by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications as I've been saying now is
not the time to be missing one piece we
are very close to the end right now and
of course relatively speaking that could
be years but still story wise we are
very close to the end and you know Oda
is going to go out with a bang we all
know that we have trust in Oda while you
wait for the full chapter review to drop
feel free to check out my huge and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos and all the yonko Warlords
Admirals like I said that's one hour
long video about Shanks which might be
the longest Shanks video on YouTube I
don't know but anyways that video is
there and much more link to that
playlist is in the description and on
screen right now drop a hashtag all hail
buggy in the comments to show your
support and until next time see ya Space
Cowboys